before the video starts guys i've come
together with montana 8 to help those
who have lost their sight to see again
just imagine enabling these people in
these countries who are blind who cannot
work and can do nothing to see again may
allah give you guys that clear sight in
the hereafter that you have enabled
people to see in this life inshallah
please donate in the link below
can an all-powerful being become weak
if he chooses to enter his creation like
he does in genesis
then he he knew where adam was yeah he
couldn't give up his prayers can he not
do that once again
can he do anything no
no
not god god can do anything i cannot do
it okay can god do anything yeah okay
can god cease to exist
if he wants to
[Music]
guys i need them
can god cease to exist if he wants to
one more time can god sees the existence
he wants to he cannot lie look can one
seem to exist he cannot lie he cannot
stop existing
all of us say wrong things i get lots of
things
that's wrong okay
can i not cease to exist thank you by
his nature because
eternal but we all get things wrong i
got lots of things